[Music]
before we start this video I want to
quickly mention that only 27 of you are
subscribed if you enjoy the content
please consider subscribing to support
the channel I've also seen some comments
saying that YouTube unsubscribed them
from the channel so please check hey
everyone welcome to another installments
of Harry Potter theory in today's video
we're going to be discussing a character
that you may have heard of I am of
course talking about the primary
protagonist for the Harry Potter story
Harry Potter himself now ever since the
last book came out Harry has been on the
receiving end of a considerable amount
of scrutiny at least from some of the
internet and I say after the last book
came out because at that stage we had a
better picture of the whole Harry Potter
story and everything that Harry had
endured before we dive in further let me
say this Harry is a talented young
wizard however what many have exercise
the series for doing it's essentially
giving Harry plot armor for those
unaware plot armor otherwise known as
script immunity or a character Shield is
essentially a term used to describe a
main character's inability to Die the
idea behind it is this the main
character is too important to the story
to be removed therefore his or her
health life are safeguarded By plot
conveniences to this I would say sure I
get it sometimes the plot seems really
out of its way to ensure that Harry
stays safe but we do have to remember
that Harry is the main character and
it's hardly unreasonable for Rolling to
keep the character around that drives
the story forward furthermore while his
life Health are always preserved his
preservation is also quite well thought
out for the most part it's not just
haphazardly jotted into the story out of
convenience traditionally books are
scrutinized for giving protagonists plot
armor when they are safeguarded by
unlikely or irregular means things that
aren't properly thought out but I think
the JK Rowling did think things out
quite well one argument for why Harry's
plot armor is so thick however the time
and time again he seems to be able to go
Toe to Toe with powerful dark Wizards
that far exceed his level of power after
all Harry didn't even know about the
Wizarding World until it was time for
him to attend Hogwarts if we look at
things reasonably how on Earth could he
have accomplished some of the things
that he did without plot armor in
today's video I want to discuss Harry's
level of power and the alleged plot
armor at play examining a bunch of
situations in which out of what some may
construe as plot convenience Harry is
bailed out from there you can make your
own decision as to whether or not you
feel that its plot armor or just
reasonable plot development was Harry a
supremely powerful wizard an untalented
and extra lucky Wizard or an above
average wizard with a considerable
amount of luck on his side first let's
jump all the way back to Harry's first
encounter with adversity his Showdown
with Voldemort on that one fateful day
in godric's Hollow October 31st 1981
wasn't only the day that beloved couple
Lily and James Potter died it was also
the day that marked the defeat of the
dark lord for the first time and the
astonishing survival of Harry when Harry
finally came of age to attend Hogwarts
his reputation having survived an attack
by the dark wood himself preceded him
and this meant that he entered a world
where he already had Fame he didn't know
the World of Magic at all but here he
was strolling down Diagon Alley with
everyone thinking that he had somehow
single-handedly stopped the dark lord so
now you might be asking how did Harry
survive well it was actually his
mother's doing Harry did nothing without
drilling down in too much baby Harry was
protected from Voldemort because of
Lily's loving sacrifice her sacrificial
protection in Harry Potter it's commonly
expressed that love trumps all other
manners of powerful magic and in this
instance that power was truly showcased
in its totality stopping the dark lord
in his tracks so Harry was saved by his
mother and this may seem awfully
convenient given that he was a baby and
quite literally unable to defend himself
against a house cat let alone one of the
most powerful dog wizards of all time
however where some may say plot armor I
simply say plot if Harry died right then
and there I'm not sure there would have
been much of a story to tell it's
established right from the beginning
that the Power of Love simply trumps all
and this is the first example of The
Power of Love In Action the next example
of Harry achieving the unthinkable comes
in the form of Harry stopping the
Basilisk in the Chamber of Secrets the
Basilisk is an ancient gigantic Behemoth
of a creature that is about as deadly as
they come however Harry in typical Harry
fashion of course bests this creature at
the tender age of 12 with virtually no
Advanced magical capability was Harry's
defeat over this Beast plot armor in my
opinion not really and I say not really
because everything that contributes to
him defeating the Basilisk seems well
thought out he doesn't outright defeat
the Basilisk with his pure raw magical
power he gets help as any protagonist
does Hermione helps him with his
research and forks shows up to help
Harry which makes perfect sense given
that Dumbledore is practically
omniscient folks shows up and Claws the
basilisk's eyes out and next the Sorting
Hat provides Harry with the Sword of
Gryffindor a sword presented to only a
true worthy Gryffindor that allows him
to defeat the Basilisk the sword thing
is a little convenient but everything
else about this situation seems
reasonable Harry's next Grand victories
came at the Triwizard Tournament in the
Goblet of Fire where he passed all of
the tournament's tests with flying
colors Harry didn't face much trouble in
the tournament and that's largely
because he always had a witness
Advantage being given help by Barty
Crouch Jr throughout however while his
assistants from Crouch Jr served him in
the tournament allowing him to
effectively pass the challenges it
didn't come without repercussions it was
always the intention of Crouch Jr to
allow Harry to win so that he would
eventually claim the Triwizard cup a
secret portkey and be transported to
little Angleton graveyard Harry passed
all of the tests and overcame any sort
of adversity that he faced but his
assistance wasn't haphazardly introduced
to continue the plot it was an integral
part of the plot the next significant
example of Harry's potential plot armor
was when he faced Voldemort in the
graveyard Harry grabs the port key in
the Triwizard Maze and is transported to
little Angleton where he is faced with
Voldemort and wormtail after taunting
Harry a bit and basically explaining
that his original defeat was a fluke
Voldemort and Harry enter into a jewel
the beams of light lock in mid-air the
two wizards are entered into a power
struggle and somehow Harry is able to
once again fend off one of the most
powerful Wizards ever however it wasn't
that Harry was more powerful than
Voldemort not even close the two entered
the stalemate for a number of reasons
first of all Lily's loving sacrifice was
still at play second of all Voldemort
had regenerated his body using Harry's
blood and third of all the two wizards
were using Brother ones the final
example of Harry's plot armor in play is
when he Jewels Voldemort at the end of
the battle of Hogwarts at this stage
Harry and Voldemort once again enter
into a magical power struggle however
what you unique about this Jewel in
particular is that Harry is no longer a
hawk rugs for Voldemort and Voldemort is
using a wand to which he is not the
rightful owner the rules surrounding the
ownership of the Elder Wand meant that
Harry was the real owner of the wand
which meant that Voldemort was not able
to kill Harry with it when Voldemort
fires his final Avada Kedavra at Harry
it bounces right back at him just as it
did so many years prior putting an end
to the dark lord forever Tom Riddle hit
the floor with a mundane finality his
body feeble and shrunken the white hands
empty the snake-like face vacant and
unknowing Voldemort was dead killed by
his own rebounding curse and Harry stood
with two ones in his hand staring down
at his enemy's shell one of the most
glaringly obvious issues with Harry is a
protagonist is that yes Voldemort wasn't
able to kill him but that shouldn't mean
that no one can kill him however for
some reason Harry is this Untouchable
important figure that the Death Eaters
must leave alone being saved and groomed
for Voldemort to eventually kill himself
so did Harry have plot convenience well
kind of yeah but I don't think that his
plot armor is quite as bad as some make
it out to be what do you guys think let
me know in the comment section below
until next time it does not do to dwell
on dreams and forget to live
[Music]